it all started at the very beginning of
seventh grade but if you could like make
one phone call you reach a whole bunch
of good sitters at the same time are you
sure this thing actually works the Etsy
shop I bought it from said it's fully
operational yeah but it's 25 years old
good rats ladies you got the
baby-sitters club premiere coming up
soon thank you you've got to be so fun
the series is awesome where you guys
have plans for premiere night so mimouna
you can go first you have any big
premiere night plans um I'm definitely
gonna stay up and watch the series of
course and I'm pretty sure we're gonna
FaceTime I'm pretty that's what we said
right we're gonna like it
I'm have this whole party on Facebook
Sophie once you pick up from there so
what are your FaceTime plan so I mean
we've got loads and loads of snacks
obviously I mean what the marathon
without snacks my little brother would
love to watch it with us because he has
added on repeat for the past like week
and I he can quote it it's so adorable
so I'm really excited for the rest of
the world to see it so good what about
you mache how are you celebrating on
premiere night day of the baby-sitters
club so always looking summon the girls
to do fun Netflix party eating lots of
popcorn drinking some fun soda and then
also I think I might invite over my best
friend from where I live do a little bit
of social distancing sake speed away but
so I just still have that fun kind of
interaction absolutely and I feel like
you know in honor of the baby-sitters
club you've got to have some Twizzlers
as well just yeah obviously the BSC
they're extremely busy as well a lot of
their time is well spent not only like
bonding and through their friendship and
of course babysitting so how much
babysitting do you girls really have IRL
well I have a lot of cousins on my dad's
side I have more than 30 so I have
there's a lot so anytime we have family
gatherings I kind of feel like I'm
babysitting
I like am responsible for some of the
younger ones like the really little ones
I just kind of carry them around
different cookies to keep their energy
up you know and then also whenever my
aunts and uncles are like doing
something for the day my sister and I
she's older by two years my sister and I
will go over to the house and like keep
watching some of the younger ones so I
would say I have quite a bit of
experience and I definitely have learned
a lot for my sister because she's had to
babysit me through the years so I kind
of know how to keep kids busy because
she kept me busy for a while yeah and I
feel like Sophie over here
girlfriends got a lot of experience on
the babysitting front if I'm not
mistaken what were you able to put your
real life into play with like playing
Kristi and stuff on screen so that was
very very easy because Kristi's got
three brothers and I've got three
brothers and I mean brothers are
interesting but not only do I babysit my
younger brothers uh my younger brothers
have like a trillion friends in our
neighborhood and we have a neighborhood
of mostly kids so I'm babysitting at
least twice a week like it is non-stop
guys but you are so you're familiar with
the business for sure my Mona are you
pretty familiar with the babies as well
as hundred percent like my mom and I
would always watch these two younger
kids and we'd have like like art the art
station and we'd always make snacks for
them and I cuz I was a little young to
be babysitting by myself so I'd always
kind of watch how my mom would take care
of them and then I see my brother and
that was a ton of fun but now he's older
so he doesn't need a babysitter anymore
but of I love kids and oh well you guys
have so much fun on the show and I feel
like you know when I was a kid I used to
love the babysitter Club books and so I
feel like you're really bringing it to
life and these gals that I thought
we're so cool I mean here they are in
the flesh now in 2020 so this is
nostalgic for me but were you all
familiar with the books at all before
booking the show and you know being cast
as one of the gals in the club Ramona
yeah I read the books growing up in
elementary school my teacher like
introduced me to the books and I just
fell in love with them and I just kept
reading more and I'd spend my lunch
hours reading the books and it was I was
so excited when the I got the script for
the reboot and I'm yeah it's awesome
what about you Shae were you familiar
with the books as well yeah so my
elastic every year oh my gosh I love the
book fair it was awesomesauce oh yeah I
remember just little nine-year-old Shay
getting steady with my coin purse like
running down to the auditorium doing
lunch and not only was it so fun to buy
like chocolate calculators and like
washi tape and random little like
stationery things like that but also
they had the baby-sitters club graphic
novels and graphic novels were so in and
cool when I was in fourth and fifth
grade
so obviously introduced those books and
I love them so much wait what about you
Miss Sophie were you a fan of the books
before the series show my oldest sister
and I have kind of a big age difference
so she had like the whole collection my
grandma bought her like every copy so it
was really awesome she passed those
books down to my other sister and I and
I'm something we could bond over
something we could share and I thought I
was so cool six-year-old man reading the
same books is 15 year old uh-huh so it
was just such a big part of my childhood
and it's so awesome to get to be a part
of it and incorporate it in Morgan
childhoods
[Music]